the latest coronavirus numbers show the
huge challenge facing president biden
on the pandemic yesterday u.s officials
reported another 4 200 deaths
so that brought the official death toll
to more than 406
000 people that's one year to the day
since we learned of the first covid19
infection in this country think about
that for just a second
so efforts to slow the spread are
starting to hit a wall with some states
running out of vaccine doses
our lead national correspondent david
begno is in east lansing michigan with
more on this story
good morning we are at michigan state
university this is where they do
livestock shows and rodeos
but three times a week they drive people
through to get them vaccinated they'd
like to add a fourth and fifth day but
they don't have enough vaccines to do
that
and that is not only the story here but
it's the story in other places around
the country
with officials saying we've got the
people we've got the logistics ironed
out
just send us more doses as vaccination
sites get bigger and busier around the
u.s
more elected officials are saying the
same thing to the federal government
double triple what you're sending us
we're ready
to provide the vaccines that's the
detroit mayor mike duggan
he says he has the full capability to
get his city fully vaccinated
in three months but he's just not
getting enough vaccine to do it
we've got the convention parking
structure where we could handle 25 000
vaccinations a week
and right now we're scheduling six
thousand we have pfizer right up the
street
in kalamazoo and they tell us they've
got vaccines the federal government
hasn't purchased but their
agreement will let them sell them to the
states so far only 22 states and the
district of columbia
have used more than half of the doses
they've received but remember both the
pfizer and modern vaccines
require two shots and to make sure they
have that second shot set aside
some officials are halting new
vaccinations
that's exactly what happened at baptist
health in miami they canceled all
appointments for their first
vaccinations
because their expected allocation did
not arrive this week
in san francisco officials say they're
going to run out of doses
today in new york city mayor bill de
blasio says they have the capacity
to vaccinate 300 000 people a week but
they're going to begin to run out of
doses today too
we've had to tell 23 000 new yorkers
who had an appointment this week that
they will not be able to get that
appointment
for lack of supply rivka press schwartz
was one of those who lost her
appointment
schwartz is a high school administrator
in the bronx it creates
anxiety and maybe even a little bit of a
sense of panic i don't quite understand
scheduling appointments for which you
didn't have doses
fair point listen regarding what the
mayor of detroit said about pfizer being
right up the road and having more
vaccines that they haven't sold to the
federal government so they could sell to
states like michigan
pfizer told cbs news they'd be more than
happy to do it but they need the federal
government
to give the approval to do so the biden
administration says next month they will
start shipping vaccines directly to
community pharmacies around the country
and that should make a big difference
anthony
it's been so frustrating david thank you